white and black airmen starting to be
skeptical of one another based on what
they were being trained to believe
asian-american airmen tired of all of
the black versus white rhetoric when i
was in the air force i was just in the
air force
politics wasn't a big part of our
day-to-day operation
do you think there's a problem with even
allowing an
idea that dangerous enter the minds of
people we have to honor their rights to
go and participate in politically
charged potentially violent and
dangerous protests like black lives
matter protests there's a big difference
between a
sudden tipping point and just a gradual
build up to
hey where did you show up out of nowhere
you're sitting here telling me i'm
racist
you see people losing their jobs if they
disagree with a particular
political stance or political ideology
and insist that to disagree
is to identify yourself as either racist
or bigoted
look just a few weeks ago everybody was
hearing this you probably saw this on tv
news you know different websites a
lieutenant colonel matthew lohmeyer
was fired uh based on a couple comments
he made on a conservative podcast
and when i saw that i was curious i
wanted to do a little bit more research
on him and you find out
here's a commander who left after being
in the air force i believe for 14 years
and decides to join space force
and is starting to see what's going on
maybe a little bit of an adjustment
that's taking place the direction
military is going in
and he comments on it now this isn't
just a soldier i was in the army i was a
63 bravo mechanic
i worked on hummers the man i'm
interviewing today
has 1200 hours of flying a t-38 as an
instructor pilot
followed by the f-15c this is not just
anybody we're talking about that served
the military
this is somebody that went to the top
became a commander made a couple
comments and by the way when you hear
him speak today you will know this is
not someone that
is a divider this is not someone that's
an opinionated that just kind of wants
to give his opinion out there and you
know
by doing podcasts this is some someone
that's very level-headed
this is someone that's coming from a
very reasonable place that's concerned
and his comments were led to him losing
his job which is unfortunate for him
uh haven't lost his job now the thing
you need to know is the fact that
whatever comments he gives us is
important for everybody to know
these are his comments it's different
than what the military stands for
he stands for his comments that has to
say just as i do as well with that being
said
lieutenant colonel uh lowe meyer thank
you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
thank you for having me i'm happy to be
here with you so
so if you don't mind taking gay because
for me you know you and i were talking
about it uh before the interview when i
was in the army
i was just in the army i was in a lot of
meetings but there was not
a lot of politics involved you just went
you got your job done
you know maybe you debated sports maybe
you debated when there was an election
time but it wasn't as divisive as
you know america is not a good country
america's you know history is not maybe
the best and we've done some really bad
things
it was more about if it wasn't for
america if it wasn't for here's what
we've done here's what the hunter first
airborne has done
and it looks like some things have
changed so do you mind you know
going from your story first if the
audience doesn't know your background
who were you you were a
champion you know you were on a
championship to basketball team kind of
walk us through that on what led to you
being
right before you're getting fired sure
thank you i suppose there's a lot to say
uh i'll be as brief as i can with some
of the personal background
but i'm grateful for the long form
interview uh
in high school i played basketball we
won the state championship
in arizona and
i was noticed my sophomore year of high
school by the air force academy
incidentally i had the best games of my
life when the air force academy
recruiting team was there watching and
the worst games of my life was some of
the other universities i was hoping to
attend
and so they they picked me up pretty
early
and i took interest in the air force
academy for the first time in my life
basically my junior and senior year of
high school i never had any military
ambition
i didn't have my parent neither of my
parents had served in the military
i'd only had one uncle who had served
active duty air force and a grandfather
who had served briefly
uh during the time period of the korean
war but i was recruited to play
basketball and and decided to
attend the air force academy i only
played basketball for one year and it
was while i was there at the air force
academy that i decided
to start taking the military obligation
seriously
and began to appreciate the importance
of military service it wasn't before i
went it was only after
i had gone well as you mentioned
after graduation from the air force
academy i spent
14 years corruptly in the air force
about half of that time i was flying
and the other half of that time i was
working in space for air force space
command
and until the creation of the u.s space
force
the air force the department of the air
force and the service
the air force was the only service
that was largely responsible for all of
our space-based capabilities and space
operations
that we did in the world and so i made
the transition into
air force space command and gained
expertise
in space-based missile warning and also
had the opportunity uniquely to travel
the world for an entire year
as the aid to camp for the four-star
uh general john raymond who was in
charge of air force base command
and see all of our space missions across
the globe it was a very unique
opportunity
and so it was also with him
interestingly during important
conversations that were taking place in
dc and elsewhere
about the stand-up and creation of a new
independent space force
and looked forward to the opportunity to
transition
into that service which i did
uh just this past year and so i've
served a little over 15 years now
total on active duty and only a little
over a year of that
has or under year of that has been in
the new service the space force
but more specifically to your point into
your question
you asked uh when it was
or how long it has been that i've been
seeing or recognizing this kind of thing
that i'm writing about speaking about
in the services like you when i was in
the air force i was just in the air
force
politics wasn't a big part of our
day-to-day
operation and i would argue that largely
speaking today throughout the services
politics still is not a big part of what
they do
however there's been a momentous shift
during the past calendar year to begin
offering
not just annual trainings but monthly
and weekly and daily conversation in
some bases depending on where you work
about race related issues they're
politicizing discussions not unifying
discussions
they're divisive discussions because a
lot of the language of critical race
theory
is being invoked something that the
american people hadn't heard a lot about
in the past before the past calendar
year but are beginning to hear a lot
about now
and as i recognized those discussions in
the form of what we call diversity and
inclusion trainings
uh stand down days uh both locally
and and also department of defense wide
i recognize
just how divisive this these discussion
points were going to become
as our down days and trainings were
starting to translate into
white and black airmen for example
starting to be skeptical of one another
based on what they were being trained to
believe
asian-american airmen coming to me and
explaining that they're tired of all of
the black versus white rhetoric and that
they're deciding to get out of the air
force
white airmen coming to me and saying
they're deciding to separate
from the from the air force or space
force because they're tired of being
accused
of racism constantly so this is the time
period
the last calendar year that i've
recognized these things really starting
to heat up
and that's been true across broader
society but also in the services
is there a single event that caused that
or was it a because there's a big
difference between a
sudden tipping point and just a gradual
you know build up to hey where did you
show up out of nowhere you're sitting
here telling me i'm racist
i don't have any problem with anybody i
just want to make sure you're performing
how did this show was it overnight or
was it gradual
the reason that's difficult to answer
properly
in my view is because the answer is both
it is both gradual and it is sudden
marxist
communist subverse subversive tactics
require years if not generations to
properly
germinate for the soil to be properly
prepared
for people's willingness to divorce
themselves from what
would be considered traditional values
and that that kind of thing takes a long
time there's a reason
those who understand and are intent upon
pushing that agenda target the education
system specifically
higher learning but also now the public
education system
our churches uh those
institutions are places where
from a very young age to
our adult life we continue to be
educated and influenced
and if you can if you can plant subtle
ideas over a long period of time all it
takes is certain tipping point
or crisis events as you pointed out to
capitalize on
in order to begin revolutionary changes
within a society
one such event uh it's just a matter of
fact i know it's controversial but was
george floyd's death
what i saw in broader society and
incidentally in the military services
this past calendar year was that that
event
was capitalized on by those who are
activists
for uh whether they realize it or not a
marxist agenda
black lives matter and antifa for
example have marxist dames
uh there are many compassionate people
who participate
in these various efforts because they're
compassionate and because they are
interested in bettering the lives of
humans
but what they don't understand is that
the
inventors of or creators of the ideology
and the agenda have a particular aim in
mind in its division not unity
it's uh it's revolution
not peaceful unification of society
and there's a particular way in which
they go about it which we've seen in the
past year
it's it's getting people angry it's
shouting slogans
it's uh tribalism and when that begins
to be injected into
our most trusted institutions like the
united states military
then what you see is the breakdown of
good order and discipline as the kind of
polarization
that typifies broader society now
infests
one of your one of your
uh purposefully non-political
organizations
as you're aware you serve in the army
it's purposefully
non-political or apolitical and and for
good reason because you can't have
people
who are dodging bullets and and
returning bullets
uh caught up in hatred towards one
another because of their tribal
identity politics so so let me let me
ask a question and then i'm gonna
you know it's technical but i think you
you'll see where i'm going with this
so who knows this is happening
who doesn't know this is happening who
knows this is happening that they
support
who knows this is happening that they
don't support those are hard questions
to answer
but i'm going to i'm going to try my
best and give my personal view
and i think it's difficult to give the
answer
accurately in a snapshot of time because
this is a very dynamic
complex societal
manifestation and what i mean by that is
to your first question who knows that
this is happening
i would have told you a year ago that
far fewer people know that it's
happening
then are becoming aware that it's
happening today in
uh july 2nd of 2021
okay for example
what i had mentioned a few minutes ago
is that very few people
heard about critical race theory or
understood that it had a marxist lineage
of ideas just a year ago
today there are groups of parents who
had never been
politically active let's say in the past
decade of their lives who are becoming
very involved
in trying to understand some of the
talking points and tactics
that are marxist in nature that is
infiltrating the school system
there are parents of who are concerned
who are sending their children off to
our service academies
who are for the first time paying
attention to what just a year previous
they might not have been aware had
marxist roots so i say that to say i
think that that's it
the answer to your first question who
knows that this is happening
i would say that there is a rapidly
growing base
of citizens in this country who are very
aware
and i'll also mention that western
liberal democracies
generally speaking are becoming aware if
they haven't already been that this is
taking
place i'm aware just personally uh based
on the fact that my book is now selling
in at least a dozen countries
primarily uh western democratic nations
uh but also some southeast asian pacific
area
nations as well the second question who
doesn't know that this is happening
well that's harder for me to answer
because i think some of those that don't
are going to come to know in the next
month or two and if
and if they don't come to know in the
next month or two or within the next
year they're going to know
probably well after it's far too late
and they should have recognized it
earlier because where this all leads to
if it's left unchecked is civil strife
continued polarization of society and
unfortunately
20th century history tells us it leads
to violence
and in fact that's a part of the agenda
a marxist agenda is to cause violent
revolution
now the the the third and fourth
questions that you've asked
uh i'm going to ask you to restate them
so i can perfectly understand it but who
who understands that this is happening
and
and either maybe supports it yes and
understands the aims of the agenda
i think that's a much smaller subset if
i've got the question
that's a much smaller subset of society
but you know douglas murray points out
in his book
uh the madness of crowds that there was
a poll taken in 2016
uh of of academics in our
college and university campuses for
example almost 20
2-0 20 of them identify publicly as
marxist
that's a shocking number and it wasn't
that high 10 years ago
that was as of 2016. i think the number
was 16 or 18
but i can't remember for sure he has a
chapter in his book on marxism effect
and it's in that chapter that he
mentions that statistic
uh but there are by far more people
who don't appreciate the danger of the
aims of the revolution
who participate nonetheless in the
movement
we've got good friends who disagree with
us uh
on these issues which in my view aren't
partisan political issues i'm simply as
a service member trying to defend
my oath to the constitution defend the
constitution and its ideals
and defend america's traditional values
let's say
that i think personally are under attack
but there are others who think that
they're highly
partisan there are also others that
think i'm either bigoted
or racist or some other hist or name
that they can come up with
because they think that if you're a
compassionate human being
naturally you would flock to these
movements
that strive for social justice that use
words like freedom
and equity or equality liberty
and of course we all care about those
words but they're defined very
differently by different groups of
people
and therefore lead to very different
ends so that's my best effort at those
four questions those are hard ones and i
think people do fall into different
categories as you've
no i think they do you've insisted yeah
i think they do and i think you're right
the group that knows who support it is a
very very small group but they're
growing so rapidly and they know how to
drive
the biggest tool i believe marxists have
today that they didn't have before
is this thing called social media that's
the biggest tool this has helped them
out
so much to drive their agenda because
they can simply go out there and
you know divide communities divide many
different people get some people to
question things you know
gaslighting hey do you really realize
what your parents are doing to you
do you really realize what your
community it's not fair that's not
that's not how they should do and
they're dividing dividing dividing but
if you don't mind that you know going
back to
the the crt critical race theory can you
can you take us back with the history of
this with
you know and i'm talking about how this
came about
freud karl marx frankfurt school antonio
gramski you know if you can go back and
break down how this whole thing came
about that in order for us to be able to
divide we need a revolution
and who came up with it and what's the
formula to make that happen
thank you there's two things i'm going
to mention the first
i want to go back to your point about
the tool of social media that we have
available
to us you'll you'll see in the news
right now that
the chinese communist party has just
celebrated its 100 year anniversary of
its creation
now for people that aren't familiar with
the history of the chinese communist
party i'll say
that go back a hundred years that's
1921. okay mao zetang
and a bunch of communist or marxist
revolutionaries
this is just several years after uh the
bolshevik revolution succeeded it's just
two years after communist party usa is
established
in the united states and communist
parties are established across
dozens and dozens of countries in the
world in the year and two following
the bolshevik revolution 1921
you have a communist party that's
established in china
but they did not notice have social
media available to them in 1921
and look at the time period involved in
the revolutionary efforts
that are slow growing like a cancer or a
metastasization
throughout rural china and getting a
uh proletariat base to rise up in
revolution against the incumbent
government
it's 1949 1949 nearly 30 years later
before a communist revolution
succeeds at pushing out nationalists to
the island of taiwan
with chiang kai-shek and other
nationalists and
and mao zedong establishes the chinese
communist party as a single party rule
within china
it's almost 30 years now you don't need
that kind of timeline
in modern america or in any modern
country that has social media to your
point
because the revolution and the ideas
of the revolution spread rapidly via
sound bites
to young vulnerable people uh who are
interested in getting
into the exciting romantic cause of
revolution
against the terrible oppressor uh now
now
transitioning into the second part the
question that you've asked about
critical race theory
whereas earlier communist
revolutions of the 20th century were
more
faithfully aligned i'll say with the
original
narrative of the communist manifesto
which was penned by marx and ingles in
specifically in an economically based
class stratification or class grouping
of people
the the bourgeoisie and the proletariat
the idea that
the bourgeoisie or the capitalist ruling
class was oppressive
and the proletariat worker class was the
oppressed
victim there's there are words like
slaves used in the communist manifesto
by marx and ingalls
to really generate a kind of visceral
animosity for those who have wealth
and who rule uh in that system
and in whatever country that narrative
might take hold
you pointed out gramsci uh i the the
communist leader
uh in italy there are many other names
i traced through in my book that some of
there are marxists that come over from
germany and flee the third reich in the
1930s
to the united states to columbia
university
and they're at the teachers college
there
in the night early 1930s in the lead up
to world war ii
these these marxist uh philosophers i'll
say
from the frankfurt school established
more firmly in the united states marxist
thought during the the decade of the
1930s and the numbers of communist party
usa during the 1930s boom
and before the decade is over tens of
thousands of new members have been added
to the communist party usa
and one of the things that gramsci
noticed
uh that was that in western society
western peoples were too wedded
to their traditional value systems that
were largely judeo-christian
okay which tended to appreciate
the value the inherent worth of the
individual
and and shy away from any kind of
revolutionary or replacement ideology
that would
instead emphasize the collective over
the individual
because there was a fear of individual
liberties being taken or threatened
and so one of the one of the ways in
which they determined
gramsci and other uh communist marxist
revolutionaries determined to
shape the narrative in the west
was that they needed a long-term plan
that was subversive they would
divorce uh western
the the civilization the populations of
western societies and specifically
uh america from their traditional values
so that they would be more susceptible
to uh the ideal
the ideas and ideals of marxism and so
there was there are books about this but
there are
lines of effort or attack and you'll
appreciate this as a military
uh man you know lines of effort are
needed to accomplish
certain ultimate aims there are many
lines of effort underway uh
that have been outlined in in many
places and they're they're easy to find
these days in books and online
and so i won't recapitulate them here
but they targeted the education system
they targeted
religious organizations they targeted
even elected
office within the united states the
senate the congress the presidency
nothing was off the table for marxist
revolutionaries they wanted to run for
office and get in and start to influence
the system from any place that they
could
so when you when you look back through
the nineteen
specifically to the nineteen thirties is
where i spent quite a bit of time
uh in my book and then there's a school
of thought that's established during
that time period called
critical theory or the critical school
of thought it's essentially the
incessant criticism of all things
western civilization
but it manifests in different ways
throughout the decades it morphs over
time for example into the 1960s and 70s
into a school of thought that's called
critical legal theory or
there's a group called the critical
legal scholars that last for decades
and they're trying to to demonstrate how
our
laws and norms that have been
established now there's a
transition to race by the way and away
from economic stratification
how whites uh white christians for
example have
established laws and norms that are
detrimental to
people of color or any other minority
group that you can
pick out of society and that morphs yet
again further still into its most
political
manifestation which is critical race
theory where they really start to
capitalize on
race dynamics and and the evil history
of slavery in this country
and racist institutionally or
systemically racist
laws of the past the evils of the past
and they resurrect those that pull them
up out of the grave
in order to build suitably unfavorable
narratives of american history and the
american people
to once again reintroduce separation
division into society with the hopes of
completely i'll use their terms
dismantling
overthrowing uh burning down the
incumbent government and the system and
ultimately establishing a one-party
system here too
so that uh one political
uh one side of the political spectrum
can be put down shut down
cancelled censured and demonized while
another can
work its way into becoming a kind of
one-party system like you see
and uh other communist revolutions or
regimes but but i mean the the part of
you know it's funny when you're speaking
it took me to iran
and i lived in iran 10 years and one of
the reasons why the shah
you know they eventually kicked them out
the second time there was
a group to shock fear the most and it
was a group called today
and two days were communists who had
escaped
lenin or stalin you know this could have
been armenians this could have been
you know russians who came to iran
because the shah
was trying to make it more westernized
and he had the battle against the
hezbollahs and
you know the extremists and today
he feared two days so much that every
two day just think about two day equals
communist same thing these are people
that swore by the book karl marx
communist manifesto my family mother's
side
they the communist manifesto bible was
first then it was the bible it was like
to them
that was their bible i grew up with that
and he kept
every time he found him he kept
arresting them he found ways to
eliminate them because he knew long term
these guys were trying to create a
revolution in iran
to divide the entire nation that was
growing at a pace that was about
to pass uk specifically with all the new
contracts of oil he was going to renew
in 1979
obviously in in the contract that was
signed in 1954
for 25 year contract with france germany
russia and i believe
us and then that was his fear
so where i'm going with this is
you know the whole idea where general uh
mark milley
who you you know general mark milley he
came out and he
uh opposed folks like yourself and
here's a man who says
look what's wrong with mike i've read
communist manifesto and i've read you
know i don't know what the other book he
talked about welfare i don't know what
the other book would have been it would
have been ein rand or atlas schragler
uh but he said another book he says i've
read both books he says i want to learn
both books what's wrong with learning
both books what's wrong with doing this
do you think there's a problem with even
allowing an idea that dangerous enter
the minds of people or are you from the
school of thought of
if we're going to develop a strong
immune system as individuals
sometimes herd immunity means you have
to face opposing ideas for you to get
stronger
what are your thoughts on that that's an
excellent
question that you've asked i think that
it's important
for us to learn history first off i'll
say that up front
the good the bad and the ugly uh it's
important
not to shy away from our ugly past as a
country either
it's one thing to study and learn about
marxism for example to study the
communist manifesto to study lenin's
writings
to study mao's writings uh what stalin
was doing
during his time in the soviet union it's
one thing
to study ideology and these things it's
an
it's an entirely different thing
altogether to
infuse our institutions with its tenants
and its
vocabulary okay entirely different it's
important and healthy to have dialogue
it's
unhealthy to impose viewpoints
political viewpoints and ideology on
people and insist that to disagree
is to identify yourself as
either racist or bigoted or and you
start throwing labels around it people
if they disagree with your views
if they disagree with your understanding
of history that's where things begin
you mentioned fear in iran there was a
fear
there is a climate of fear that we've
generated for ourselves very rapidly in
this country
where we politicize the environment
and you know you see people losing their
jobs if they disagree with a particular
political stance and political ideology
well i'll tell you what that translates
into
in an organization like our armed forces
and this is a very important point
our service members in my view
shoulder an unfair burden of remaining
apolitical
when political ideology comes face to
face with them
and they've been trained their entire
lives to know that they're supposed to
remain apolitical because to disagree
is to necessarily be viewed as
politically partisan
but to sit silent because of a climate
of fear
is to allow for you your values
your belief systems your own viewpoint
to be steamrolled by a different
uh incompatible political ideology
now i think that if an individual
is interested in studying marxism or
critical race theory or ibrahim kendy's
book how to be an anti-racist
you know these various ideas that have
been swirling around in the media in the
past
few weeks and months that is completely
their pro
prerogative that's completely their
prerogative they can study it now
if they're studying it to understand the
enemy that's great especially as an
active duty service member who's sworn
enough
to defend the constitution study and
learn about
the regimes and ideology that we've
spent at least a half a century
combating with blood and treasure
we've sent millions of troops into
combat
in the last half century to combat
marxist communist regimes and ideology
and now to criticize it it's politically
partisan
i mean we're in a dangerous spot now
if you want to go study hitler's mine
comp
because you're interested in learning
about the evils that led to great
atrocity then go study it
but when we so the point that i'm making
is it's one thing to study history and
there's danger in burying history and
there's a reason that in mao's cultural
revolution in 1966 they had book
burnings
throughout the country there's a reason
that when marxist revolution gets
underway we topple statues
and insist that that certain viewpoints
are acceptable and others are not
in american society we should we thrive
on the study of of history understanding
the past
and then valuing and cherishing
america's founding philosophy
and when we get away from that and
insist that it's
again i'll make the point when we infuse
our institutions with the tenets
the vocabulary and the ideology of it
of any of any particular ideology but
specifically marxist ideology which is
what i've been focused on
to the detriment of american philosophy
and and founding ideology the idea that
the individual has inherent worth
then we're starting to walk a road where
you become exceptionally divided because
there will always be freedom loving
america loving americans
who will never abandon those those
beliefs who will fight against
uh those divisive ideologies which we've
recognized in history have
have been antithetical to our own do you
do you think it's okay for us to have
communistic professors like those who
are openly i'm a communist i believe in
communism
do you think we ought to allow folks to
be professors who believe in communism
i've never been asked that question i
could give you an answer that i might
change the way i say it a week from now
sure but i'll say that
i'm surprised that we've got people
hanging on to marxism and communism as a
viable ideology for governance of
humanity
at this point considering that it's
produced tens of millions if not over
100 million deaths in the last century
when it's been instantiated as a
single party system in various countries
that has
completely tyrannized populations of
people
so that's the first thing i'll say is
that i'm surprised that in
a country like america
that's somehow a viable alternative to
the american philosophy that has
produced
such equality and such wealth such uh a
standard of living
such a successful multi-racial country
that's never been seen in the history of
our planet now
it's for the very reason that we
appreciate diversity
in this country and diversity of thought
and opinion that i suppose
it's even possible that people would
have such views and i think they're
entitled to those views
but specifically when it manifests in
the military let's say
now when those beliefs begin to manifest
as
advocacy for violent revolution i
identify in one in my book that
there are active duty service members
and there are not many but there's
plenty because we've got
hundreds of thousands of service members
who are online on their social media
accounts advocating for burning down
cities in this country
that is first off illegal and i'm
surprised
that not a single senior leader in our
defense department has asked me
any further questions about some of the
specific examples that i've mentioned in
my book
because if it was let's say in my in my
view if it was the other way around and
i said hey i'm aware of some white
supremacist
uh ideology that's floating around or
i'm aware of some white nationalist
extremists
uh i'd have them pounding down my door
asking for some specifics right
so there seems to be a double standard
and that's the perception that many
people have
it's one thing to believe something
we're entitled to believe as we wish in
this country it's another thing to allow
that to manifest into revolutionary
behavior that threatens
the overthrow of our way of life and our
government
we're a sovereign country we have to
defend our way of life and that's what
i've signed up to do
marxist revolutionaries are intent upon
the overthrow
of our way of life and and to put in
place of it something that is altogether
different
now there's a there's specific language
in the oath that i take
that many that all of our service
members take that we're to defend the
constitution of the united states
against
all enemies foreign and domestic
now what service members have to grapple
with is what is a domestic enemy
now you might have different opinions
about what that is but
i would say someone who's intent upon
the overthrow
of our way of life and our government
who hates the constitution
and who wants to demonize america and
americans based on
their group identities that's
antithetical to our values and it's
actually a threat
to our continued the preservation of
individual liberties in this country
and so at very least what i have to do
and what others have to do is be
courageous in identifying
what they perceive as threats so that we
can tee up the conversation about how
we're going to handle those threats
instead there's a politically partisan
push right now
to define and determine what
the domestic enemy and the domestic
threats is uh
that's been in fact recently identified
at you know global warming is something
we're focused on our global climate
change
and white supremacy and uh
there have been two senior leaders at
least that i'm aware of uh the commander
of u.s strategic command
four star and the commander of u.s space
command who are both asked by the
congress if they're aware of any white
supremacy in the services
uh if they've ever met any in their in
their careers
and they both answered negatively they
they weren't aware of any of this
problem in our services and so it
surprises me
that that's one of the most the most
pressing domestic threats that we're
trying to face right now
i'm not saying it's not ever been an
issue or
isn't an issue in some pockets of
society but to identify it as a threat
to our to our trusted institution the
military is something that i don't
personally see and completely disagree
with
but it's not me to decide the policy
yeah so i mean i'm sure you saw the
professor that came out from riverside
city college assatar bayer
and economics economics professor
who is a self-identified communist
speaking highly
of joseph stalin you know he was a
successful
revolutionary a great listener just
talking to him i'm talking about him as
if he's this
you know righteous leader that we had i
asked that question when i asked you
do you think communist uh open public
open
communists should be able to be
professors in our system
if that question was asked should a
white supremacist
be a professor in america today what do
you think the answer would be within a
split second
oh it'd be absolutely not so why should
a communist be
allowed to be a professor i mean i i see
both as extremes
my question is more why are we allowing
extremists to be professors i want to
show you
data here which you were kind of talking
about the membership of communist party
uh while you were speaking i just did
the search this is
national membership by year from 22
to 1950 right and you see it it
increases a little bit right after war
obviously the date you gave
bolshevik was 1917 u.s was 1919 and
china was 1921
it's almost every two years one of them
came out with their chinese with their
communist party so the the memberships
going up
while the economy is bad but the moment
the economy improves
membership goes down the moment 1929
crash happens
look how the membership goes up because
it's all you know
they need they need a massive crisis for
them to push their agenda
the moment economy recovers their
memberships goes down
it's such a tough time for these guys
today to make their argument
because the rich are getting richer and
the poor
are getting richer so it's you know this
saying
where the rich are getting richer and
the poor are getting poorer
the only part that that makes sense is
the following i was a kid that grew up
in a family where my dad was a 99 cents
for cashier in inglewood
my dad never sat me down and explained
to me what a 401k
my parents have never owned the 401k my
parents have never owned the stock
a mutual fund an annuity an insurance
policy a life insurance policy
never owned the house i've never lived
in a house i've always lived in an
apartment complex nobody told me
here's what rule of 72 is here's what
buy you know here's what uh
buy and hold this here's what the dollar
cost averaging is here's what a roth ira
is i
i don't know any of that kind of stuff
my dad was a cashier at 99 cent store
he was making 1500 bucks a month is what
he was making so
that was never taught to me about how
money worked
and so gradually the rich got richer and
the poor's getting richer we're making
more money yeah every
in every possible way life is getting
better better
so their argument isn't working so in
order for them to effectively impose
their argument
they have to go back to what you were
talking about antonio
gramsci which you know he talks about
cultural hegemony which i'm sure you're
familiar with cultural hegemony
if by the way i don't want to read the
definition would you mind taking a quick
second here and telling everybody what
culture hegemony is i'm sure you've
spoken about this in your book i do
write about it in the book
uh he's written there's a there's a
short
if i'm not mistaken there's a short
paper even that you can go read about
this um
understanding cultural hegemony but we
we did touch upon it earlier it's
this idea as you pointed out look at the
graph that you
that you put up on the screen there
remember remember there was
frankfurt school marxists that come over
into the united states
uh on the tail end of that crash in at
the beginning of the 1930s and you see
the communist party usa numbers boom
during that period
and it's the same time period
that gramsci and others are pushing this
idea
that you have to divorce people in
western society
from their traditional values their
traditional culture their traditional
norms
and you need to replace it with a
different set of values a different set
of norms in a different culture
and if you're able to do that
successfully now as you pointed out the
economic stratification argument the
idea that the working class is going to
continue getting poorer
and need to rise up in revolution
against their their captors
the capitalist ruling class that was
not a successful narrative to use to
spur
violent revolution in a place like the
united states
but that's when that same time period
where the numbers are booming there
and when we're talking about cultural
hegemony antonio gramsci and others that
are grabbing a hold of that idea that we
should divorce
people from their traditional values and
replace it with a separate
ideology during that same period is when
you see the development of both critical
theory and it morph
into critical legal theory let me read
you something from my book just briefly
here please
that i've got because it gets right at
it's going to take me 10 seconds to find
it so
here it is it actually took me three
seconds to find it you're good
page 102 of my book so today
critical legal scholars at harvard
university help us make the link between
critical legal theory and the now
popular and pervasive
critical race theory uh the harvard
berkman klein center has a page
on on their website about critical legal
theory today
specifying what it is and it and it's
related to what we're talking about
critical legal theory scholars focused
from the start this is a direct quote
from their website
on the ways that law contributed to
illegitimate social hierarchies
okay pay very close attention to the
language producing domination of women
by men
non-whites by whites and the poor
by the wealthy this is a pr classic
oppressor versus oppressed narrative
that is showing up in our high our educa
institutions of higher learning they
claim
this is again still a direct quote from
the harvard uh berkman klein center's
website
they claim that apparently neutral
language and institutions
apparently neutral language and
institutions
operated through law mask relationships
of power
the emphasis on individualism within the
law similarly
hides patterns of power relationships
while making it more difficult to
summon up a sense of community and human
interconnection now
let me connect that quote from harvard's
website
uh now this is critical legal theory
this is a half century old
to the current uh far more politicized
critical race theory ibram kendy's book
how to be an anti-racist has come up
uh a number of times in the media in the
last few months and specifically in the
last week i've talked about it
in the introduction to his book and this
is this is going to be
some quotes directly from his book candy
mentions that color blindness
martin luther king jr's uh dream and
ideal for
western society and for american society
specifically color blindness
is racist passivity these are not my
words these are candies words
color blindness is a mask to hide
racism and the constitution of the
united states is a colorblind racist
constitution
for a white supremacist america
those are ideological talking points
that are rooted in marxism with the
intent on dividing the american people
okay so you can see how
cultural the idea of cultural hegemony
planted
planting the seeds of division over time
in our
institutions of higher learning manifest
today tactically and methodologically
in the writings of critical race
scholars and then he goes on to say
if you consider yourself not racist i
don't care what your race is i don't
care what your political party is
that is that is the language of
neutrality
not racist you are either racist and
admit it
or you're racist and you deny it
confirming your racism
if you claim to be not racist you are
quote like the trumps
and other white supremacists of the
world now
what is problematic about this is not
that somebody
believes it because lots of people
believe stupid things
what's problematic about it is that it's
being
recommended to our service members
as something that's going to help them
navigate the complex
world that we find ourselves operating
in and
it's a distraction from our main focus
which is to prepare to deter and if
necessary to fight and win the wars that
our nation calls upon us to fight and
win
and we've got serious enemies in the
world who want to see our disillusion
like china
and i can't help but imagine that
if you are an active i think there's 90
million people in the chinese communist
party which is like
six percent of the 1.4 billion people in
china
only it's like less than 10 percent of
their population is actively
uh participate participating member in
the chinese company's party if you're xi
jinping
if you're his advisors if you're the
leaders of the ccp
and the pla people's liberation army
military
forces there's nothing that you'd like
to see more
than for american service members
who provide a certain traditional
integrity to
the united states and the western world
let's say and a defense of it
who aren't political to start getting
wrapped up
and divided over marxist rooted
uh political ideology because they know
very well where that leads at least to
revolution
and so if i were them and i i'm not
planting ideas they already do this
i'd be actively engaged on social media
platforms like you mentioned
with bots and other personalities
dedicated to fomenting
the i the revolution by planting these
sound by ideologically based
uh snippets of of trash that come from
people's books like kenny's books you
get people to believe that they'll start
to hate other people based on their
group identities
you know i will tell you what you just
said was very powerful but earlier when
we were talking about
the membership goes when goes up when
the economy is bad
you know we have less
welfare today less poverty the rich only
reason rich
rich's net worth goes higher than
poorest doesn't rich knows where the
investor money poor doesn't know where
to investor money
you know when i was a guy who didn't
have money i was putting my money in the
bank the rich looks at opportunities
investments have to learn how to do that
by getting into the financial industry
but i want to read this
from wikipedia i just want to read it
from wikipedia so the audience can go
look for it
here's cultural hegemony when earlier uh
uh we were talking about uh antonio
gramsci this
is him okay antonio gramsci the marxist
intellectual developed the
notion of hegemony and adverts advocated
the establishment of a working-class
intelligence intelligentia so in marxist
philosophy culture germany is a
domination cultural diverse
society by the ruling class which
manipulates of the the culture of the
society the beliefs
manipulates it manipulates the culture
of society that believes
explanation perceptions values mores so
that the imposed ruling class worldwide
becomes
accepted cultural norm the universally
valid dominant ideology which justifies
the social political
and economic status quo as natural and
inevitable
perpetual and beneficial for every
social class
rather than a as artificial social
construst
that benefits only one ruling class so
in
in other words the way i take it is look
let's confuse the hell out of everybody
let's confuse them
and if you look at in the last 18 months
what was the biggest thing that the
marxist movement got
that helped them drive that agenda even
more maybe not 18 months 15 months
it's covered why covet shut us down
so california new york illinois
michigan a lot of these states shut down
texas
florida many of these places were open
while these other states were not but
this shutdown
got us to accept sending people money
paying people for their rent the person
who owns that real estate property that
needs to collect rent is not getting
rent not from the government not from
the individual
they got a little bit of the ppp loan
but they're sitting there saying i can't
sustain this for for
too long oh let's extend the moratorium
but
remember what do you want me to do well
you got you're rich you can afford it
dip into your savings but i just barely
bought this
duple you know this apartment i don't
have that much money in the bank account
i'm going to run it doesn't matter you
are rich
you're categorically rich you got to be
able to pay for this
and gradually people said maybe this
marxist stuff isn't that bad maybe this
saying we can send money to people we
can print money or we can send money to
people
in the last 15 months i would have to
say to you
they made so much progress in the last
15 months
the agenda has won so much because the
divisiveness the the division the
them being divided has advanced them so
much
are you optimistic that
based on history tough
heroes rise up that are not afraid to
bully the bully
or are you in a place where you feel
we're at a tipping point
where their agendas unfortunately gonna
advance
even more today than ever before simply
because they have the tools today that
they did not have
a hundred years ago when this movement
began
okay you've asked a terribly important
question
um so if if people have been partially
listening up to this point i hope
they'll listen very carefully
during the covet crisis that we've that
we've
been subject to and also subjected
ourselves to
active duty service members it was tough
for us to get
even our service members to work
sometimes if they were non-mission
essential personnel
because we would like so many other
businesses or organizations cut down on
the number of people that were
that were allowed to come to work
instead of 100 percent manning you went
to 75
then you went to 50 and at one point
you're down to 25
manning and so our service members are
staying at home
trying to telework and it was different
from base to base this was not
you know top-down driven policy base to
base
because it was too dangerous to come to
work but there were waivers being
granted for people to go downtown
in various cities and participate in
black lives matter rallies
that were smashing windows and lighting
things on fire
okay now now we have
we have a right to go and participate in
rallies protests etc just not in uniform
okay so i'll make that clear
work we're saying that
in fact it was the office of special
counsel that that determined
black lives matter last year they
determined that black lives matter is
not a politically partisan organization
it's not involved in politics it's not a
political organization
which is false it's completely political
uh and its founders have said so since
at least 2015 in interviews they said
remarxist democrat party
is not far left enough for us we need to
move to socialism
uh we have a marxist agenda uh we're
trained marxist organizers and we're
trying to revolutionize the system okay
that's all
very clear language so it is very
political
now to say that service members cannot
come to work
because it's too dangerous because of
covet but that because but we have to
honor their rights
to go and participate in protests even
highly politically charged and
potentially violent and dangerous
protests like black lives matter
protests
turned into during the last year is a
very odd
to say to put it lightly double standard
but here's to your point the question of
where we stand
as a country am i optimistic about
potential outcomes and what courageous
voices can do
this is why it's the crux of the matter
it's why it's so important to me
as an active duty service member to
speak up now
early and often about what i'm seeing
take place for people that don't
understand history i get that you might
be at odds with me or disagree with my
method
my approach my tactic uh it's been
embarrassing somewhat for the services
for me to be talking publicly i
understand that completely but what is
far worse
is for people to not say anything if
they recognize how dangerous a path
we're walking
and to wait a year or two or three until
it's far
too late for us to reverse the
radical trend that's occurring in our
society to a
to a single
to a single party system i'll say i'm
not talking just
i'm not talking republicans versus
democrats at all here i'm talking about
the establishment of a marxist communist
regime
in this country and you're saying we're
well on our path to doing that
that sounds like conspiracy theory to
some people
a year ago some people are waking up now
this year and in this month to the fact
that that's entirely possible
our country is not in any way
different or unique than uh unique from
any other country in human history
that is susceptible to revolutions if we
abandon our traditional values and are
willing to buy into ideology
we are exactly the same because humans
are the same human nature is the same
we are at a perilous crossroads in
american history at the moment
otherwise i would not have put my
potentially put my career on the line
to speak openly about this i'm trying to
be courageous to be get
courage and yet if not enough people
wake up and get courageous it might not
be enough
to stem the tide of radicalism that i'm
seeing sweep across the country at the
moment
fortunately i'm grateful for grassroots
movements
parrots retired military officers even
active duty service members who are
starting to speak up against this
and starting to recognize this for just
how dangerous it really is there's a
group called stars
stand together against racism and
radicalism and the services
and they have a website stars with two
r's stars.us
they were just formed in the last couple
of months and they've got thousands of
people that have signed up to join them
trying to fight critical race theory in
the services for example
there are movements and organizations
like that who are taking courage
and i'm hopeful that at least in the
near term we're going to be successful
at erecting barriers
to the revolutionary cause and taking
back some of our
uh foundational values and allowing
the democratic process between parties
in this country to play out
on the civilian stage among government
officials elected officials in our
civilian population on the one hand
and on the other hand allowing our
services to return to being
non-political
not politicized so our service members
don't get divided over these political
ideologies
what's next for you you you sound uh
you sound like you got a potential big
upside but
uh meaning if you ask for i don't know
what your aspirations are but what's
what's next for you
so i'm still active duty i'm not in
command
uh there's i hear from reading in the
media an investigation that's ongoing
about me
but i've not been informed of that in
writing or verbally from my chain of
command and so
you know i i get legal counsel i wait
and i
and i sit and i wait and i see what the
outcomes of this uh
supposed investigation are going to be
uh i
i've had the understanding and ambition
that i would be a leader within our
service uh within the space force for
for a very long time now
the service has said it's lost its trust
and confidence is in me as a leader
so unless it wants to publicly say
otherwise that it's changed its mind
that i'm actually doing something
worthwhile and good
uh rather than just being a
controversial figure
i don't know how i could ever return to
leading people in the services
if the services have labeled me as
controversial and untrustworthy that's a
terrible position
to be put in uh and i very much have
been grateful for the opportunity to
lead well that's been taken
so i don't know is the short answer to
your question what my future holds
whether it's in the service or out of
the service
but i am very interested in my oath to
defend this
the country's constitution because
it produces a society that values
individuals it produces a society
that enables people to thrive regardless
of their beliefs their cultural
background their upbringing
and to pursue uh to pursue excellence in
society to be contributors to help
to genuinely help contribute to the
benefit and welfare of other human
beings regardless
of their race their politics their
beliefs that's the greatness of the
american ideal
right now that's under attack whether
people want to believe that or not and i
think
a great many people are starting to
believe that any political aspirations
or no
i've i've always had zero political
aspirations really
really i've had zero political
aspiration
there are a lot of people it seems have
political aspirations for me at the
moment
but i've never had political aspirations
i wrote a book about political ideology
not not interested in getting
politically partisan
um i'm hopeful that our
elected officials will be actively
engaged
in first helping
remove the highly politicized talking
points and environment within our armed
forces that have crept in in the past
years
especially but i'm also hoping that
they'll
that that citizens will get involved
with their their state
local governments uh on school boards
and other things i mean this is my
personal views people need to get
involved right now and not wait another
month
uh otherwise it might be too late they
need to get involved and be active and
dialogue that's respectful
so that we can prevent the kind of
divisive and potentially violent
revolution that some hope for in this
country
uh and i've seen a lot of this in the
news in the past they're getting a lot
of press recently there's a lot of
people that are
getting very involved and courage begets
courage
and i'm grateful for people getting
involved right now but political
aspiration
uh i'll say not today
yeah i mean it's it's a again the way
you
speak is very uh
the way you put words together as you're
explaining is so clear it's crystal
clear like you're just speaking the
truth and you're going through it
and i think in politics that could help
you out and you don't seem like you're
an emotional guy
and god knows we already know what
happens when
we get a little too emotional it tends
to only give fire more to the opposing
side
favorite uh favorite um
pilot in the movie top gun which one's
your favorite just curious oh man
i didn't even like the movie get out of
it seriously i didn't like it
no i didn't it was too cheesy too corny
that's it
you know wow so yeah like you didn't
like uh maverick right in the bike back
to
her place you didn't like all that no
that was i know that bugged me
really so what's your favorite fighter
pilot movie if you could say one that
you liked what
would it be this is going to disappoint
a lot of fighter pi
there was a really good it might be
called fighter pilot actually
it was like in imax theaters uh where
you got to get some real good
inside the cockpit gopro footage of what
it's actually like to fly in a fighter
that was kind of fun
i forget it's been years since i've seen
it it might be called fighter pilot
though
interesting um and uh the
hollywood uh fighter movies
just have never uh been that exciting to
me
that's sad isn't it listen i mean i mean
i played i played the
high school and then for a short season
college basketball and yet you asked me
my favorite basketball team i'll also
disappoint you i don't even pay
attention anymore
uh so you you so you you become a
fighter pilot because you watched the
movie or was it family no no
so how did it happen okay so here's see
much more exciting than a hollywood
movie i was
a biology uh student at the air force
academy
intending on going to med school and
i went out to edwards air force base
where they had the test pilot school uh
out there and i got a an incentive
flight
in a t-38 and had the time of my life
sitting in that back seat raging around
in the desert out there
and it i changed my major i pursued
pilot training
and uh i loved i loved it it was tough
work but i loved uh
i loved flying well uh brother thank you
for your service lieutenant colonel you
know well
for me a man who changed my life i got a
list of 10 men who changed my life in a
positive way one of them was
lieutenant colonel peacocks whom till
today i was in dc
seven years ago i saw a man walking by
and it was like a two or three star i'm
like
that looks like lieutenant colonel
peacocks i walked up to him it wasn't
i'm still looking for him till today
but you being a lieutenant colonel i am
sure you have imp impacted many young
men's lives
and they probably look at you as a
leader you have the presence of a leader
i thank you for your service
and some tells me you got a big upside i
don't know what you're going to be doing
but i think you'll be doing something
that's going to positively impact
this great country that my family
escaped to come to
thank you for your time i appreciate
your words of encouragement
uh i appreciate i started paying
attention to your uh
interviews and your and valuetainment
actually after being invited to be on
the show and i've
enjoyed going and looking at how you
interview people and uh
you're open-minded and balanced and uh i
really appreciate the work that you're
doing so thank you
thank you thanks for coming on as it
gets time by the way folks if you're
watching this we're going to put the
link below to his book
irresistible revolution marxism's goals
of conquest and unmaking of the american
military
that link will be below go order his
book take care everybody bye-bye
what do you think about what he had to
say do you agree with them do you not
agree with them thumbs up you agree with
them thumbs down you don't agree with
them if you do or don't comment below i
thought it was so
interesting to see military i mean i
understand media i understand hollywood
i understand even universities
but military military where a commander
has to go through walking on exos the
way he had to go through and he gets
fired for it
i don't know i want to hear your
comments comment below and if you
enjoyed this interview there's two
others i think you'll enjoy one of them
is uh
with paul kanger professor author uh his
specialty we talked about it was a very
very interesting
uh he gave the history of marxism karl
marx who he was what he did that's his
specialty
and another interview i did with michael
malus who has a complete different
perspective of what direction he thinks
america ought to go to he's a famous you
you know he's you see him in a lot of
interviews
on youtube click over there to watch his
interview haven't said that have a great
one everybody take care bye